non perderti anita stories la serie
animata un nuovo episodio ogni domenica
alle 12 sul mio canale
benvenuti su anita stories oggi
nuovissima challans un po particolare
dovrò trovare non gli ingredienti slime
ma i regali di natale nascosti da non da
babbo natale normale ma da granny granny
babbo natale
praticamente se non avete visto l'altro
video in cui giochiamo a grandi babbo
natale andate a vederlo dopo questo
video granny per natale si è trasformata
in babbo natale o inquietante anzi un
bel po come sempre gremi lo è sempre
comunque dovrò trovare quattro i regali
di natale nascosti dal g
ovviamente i regali non sono fatti da
granny ma sono fatti da altre persone 20
se fossero fatti da gremi penso che
troverei non lo so dei ragni dei verdi
[Musica]
sono dimenticato di dirvi che treni può
comunque prendermi per cinque volte
[Musica]
cento
e sei treni mi prende per cinque volte
avrò perso la challenge affrontarsi a
lasciare i regali che riesco a
recuperare entro le cinque punte posso
tenerli ma se non riesco a recuperare
dei regali entro cinque giorni non potrò
più prenderli
ma lo sapevamo già sprecato un giorno
perché dovevamo comunque ospitarvi le
regole del gioco altrimenti non si
capiva e vabbè mi ha già preso una volta
granny babbo natale ma ora sbrighiamoci
cerchiamo questi regali altrimenti non
potrò prenderli né aprirli perché ho
solo quattro giorni adesso allora
ovviamente voi se notate qualcosa
scrivetelo nei commenti
scrivetemi nei commenti voi cosa avete
chiesto per natale cosa sperate di
ricevere o se guardate questo video dopo
natale cosa avete ricevuto sono molto
curiosa siamo un po forse in mezzo ai
pupazzi non mi sembra che ci sia niente
ma questo non c'era qua prima o sbaglio
molti ho trovato il primo regalo viva
l'ingegnere vicino i pupazzi c'è sempre
qualcosa qualche indizio qualcosa
andiamo ad aprirlo assieme secondo me
che cos'è secondo me è a una forma
strana una barretta di cioccolato quindi
forse sarebbe stato un regalo per vitale
non per me vediamo apriamolo se in
questo video raggiunge i 15 mila mi
piace ci sarà anche una seconda parte in
cui dovrà trovare i regali nascosti da
decidetelo voi qua nel sondaggio non mi
ricordo se qua ho qua potete decidere
poi quale sarà il prossimo personaggio
da cui dovrà trovare i regali o le miss
il box perfette con le mistery box
quindi votate e lasciato mi piace mi
raccomando vediamo ora cosa se qua
dentro provate a indovinare nei commenti
qualcosa di rosa corta pippo si fanno e
una cover per il mio telefono ed è anche
di uno dei miei colori preferiti rosa
chiaro e bellissimo apriamo la proviamo
subito nel telefono ma mi sa che ho
lasciato il telefono nell'altra stanza e
ho paura che gravi sia lista proviamo ad
andare lo stesso allora apriamo la
vediamo se è un bellissimo colore
guardate è un rosa cipria mi piace un
sacco bene finora sta andando molto bene
questo gialle ora andiamo a cercare gli
altri regali e anche il mio telefono
così possiamo provarlo non mi sembra che
ci sia nessuno fortuna telefono qui
ecco qua allora avevo una cover
trasparente rena e voleva una cover
colorata quindi proviamo la vediamo come
questa breve storia triste cercando di
togliere la cover dal mio telefono lo
spaccata guardate perché la troppo
rigido togliere l'ho tirato e non
spaccato trovato questa cover costava
danti vivo vabbè ma non male per me non
è un altro però banda giovedì spiaggia
che ecco qua la nuova cover devo dire
che il colore molto carino un po color
cipria e sarà l'unica cover che
utilizzerò perché l'altra sono stata
molto intelligente da spaccarla qualcosa
dietro
film
no credimi ha preso di nuovo ma questa
volta è colpa mia perché ho fatto un
sacco di casino con quella cover
comunque ho solamente tre giorni adesso
cerchiamo bene quale magari ci siamo
persi qualcosa qualcosa stanza che
perché penso che i treni sarà la nella
camera da letto
vi faccio vedere un regalo che mi sono
fatta io da sola banda sé stessa e
questa ha ora è spenta comunque una lava
lamp alti presente le lampade che hanno
la c'era dentro e ci sono le bollicine
che salgono su io li ho sempre adorato
sono tipo ipnotizzanti ma sono regalato
da solo poi me la farò mettere anche
accesa ma un'altra volta
adesso non abbiamo molto tempo
devo tornare nella stanza da letto
il berlino berlino dimmi c'è qualcuno là
dietro di vita inizi c'è qualcuno alla
camera c'è qualcuno io gioco a porta e
capita lo spettacolo meno male contro lo
stato che stava parando berlino era
proprio dietro la porta
ok allora dobbiamo aspettare un po
magari controlliamo meglio queste c'è
qualcosa ma sicuramente non possiamo
andare là dentro
io l'ho trovato solo un re calmo ne
mancano tre cioè soccorso non penso che
i treni resta ad aprire qua che cos'è
questa busta
vediamo subito che cos'è sembra un libro
sembra proprio un libro
ok siamo due regali di quattro per ora
sta andando bene vediamo che libro è
questo strano il fatto di legno ma non
ho nessuna copertina com'è possibile che
cosa parla di niente ha forse è un
agenda quindi devo scrivere io dentro
evitiamo è un libro luminoso che
s'illumina ha cambiato colore diventato
verde come la maledizione del verde come
poteva saperlo è un libro magico allora
fare blu nuovo fantastico
penso che sia una sorta di lampada
portatile è fighissimo è rimasto più di
un consigliere
guardate sia profila così
e bellissimo pezzo regalo fine mostra
super contenta
regione vediamo il prossimo colore sarà
il colore preferito di gremi vediamo
arancione il prossimo colore è il mio
colore preferito vediamo
sì è vero mi piace celeste in rosa il
prossimo colore è il tuo colore
preferito vediamo se indovina blu
scrivete nei commenti si ha indovinato
se un altro posto il colore preferito
rosa ok mi piace un sacco casta libro
bellissimo sembra un libro normale ma in
realtà è una lampada magica
wow ok smetterla di perdere tempo
devo andare a trovare gli altri
ingredienti no non ingredienti devo
andare a trovare gli altri due regali
altrimenti non ce la farò mai andiamo
già trovato due regali qua quindi ho
come l'impressione che gli altri due
potrebbero essere la o in qualche altra
stanza perché non penso che io abbia
nascosti
non c'è premi per fortuna li lasci
andare fino questa festa sta impazzendo
toccano questo accordo con te cari
questi l'inizio del vero il silenzio sì
lo so che vuoi giocare ma non e il
momento adesso arriva dai ti prometto
che dopo giochiamo
allora penso guardate qua fianco magica
se non penso che sia un regalo e tipo
sorta di cilindro
non so cosa potrà esserci qua dentro
rumore strano
secondo me c'è una lampada non lo so far
rumore mostrano grazie magica mi ha
aiutato a trovare il terzo ragazzo non
so cosa potrei essere questo va beh
[Risate]
escludono scarpa scatto scatto scatto
per un pelo per poco non mi prendeva che
cosa stava facendo si stava specchiando
è sempre così vanitosa g comunque siamo
riusciti a prende il terzo regalo ne
manca solo uno sicuramente sarà nascosto
molto bene l'ultimo ma per ora apriamo
questo finale secondo voi cosa c'è qua
dentro
[Musica]
che cos'è un cilindro a questo serio
bottiglia riutilizzabile tipo quelle
delle visto che e io ne ho già una rosa
e questo ancora più bella
questo colore al 100 e adoro perché
tengono le bevande fredde e anche caldo
e per un sacco di oro e un fatto di
cuore andiamo a cercare l'ultimo regalo
forse possiamo farcela
[Musica]
b arriva
che succede tutto solo perché mi sono
svegliata qua o no che cavolo è successo
treni natale mi sta osservando che cosa
devo farti rimanere qua immobile fino
aiutavi marino
aiutami tu distrae la che cosa mi ha
preso un'altra volta quindi solamente
due giorni ma penso che sia molto
difficile spostarsi d'acqua
forse posso provare a passare sopra il
letto non smette
a parlarci signora o signore non so se
maschio femmina granny babbo natale non
è che mi lasceresti passare per favore
non ho fatto niente di male forse non
capisce provo a parlare in inglese gli
speak english sono richard ok forse
parla solo una sua lingua il bravissimo
marino previsti che trovate il quarto
racalmuzzi credo veramente valide vuoi
dire vi era sul letto nascosto sotto i
cui semi non avrei mai trovato se non
avessi provato a scappare dal 1 st
meglio che sarà la porta berlino berlino
berlino maledetta che metta da mai e
quando mi crede che molte berlino ma io
riconosco la base di berlino spero che
non apro la porta
adesso mette ad aprire questo lega lo
avremo
sale così a scoprire il mondo magico
guardate sempre i bruttini può
bellissimo le scale ministero della
magia entry
ritraccia tiro smith fa bellissimo non
ho mai visto un libro fatto così in pay
portar bene mi sono riuscite a scartare
tutte il potere regale iscrivetevi
commento quale vi è piaciuto di più
il libro la bottiglia l'altro libro però
in realtà non è un libro o la cover per
cellulare ma nel frattempo dov'è finita
credi a berlino sei tu mi sono
spaventato medico berlino se non
riuscite dal previsto tre legali vuoi
vedermi no non puoi farne niente perché
amo fare tutto cio in quanto gli regalo
vinto la challenge
lo abbiamo fatto anche questa volta
abbiamo vinto contro i gremi mira cose
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete un
altro video in cui devo cercare i regali
o le miss dei box da qualche altro
personaggio a 15 mila mi piace si sarà
un altro video mi raccomando se non
avete ancora visto lite astori sulla
serie animata sono già usciti tre
episodi quindi cliccate qua per vedere
l'intera serie animata e ora vi lascio
qua 4 caselline su cui cliccare per
vedere i miei altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite e buona visione